kinda good morning Hank it's Tuesday so
in addition to giving us the stethoscope
the Adirondack chair in the state of New
Mexico tuberculosis is a little bit
maybe gave us World War one so we all
know the causes of World War One from
Crash Course right the complicated
alliance system in Europe the growing
militarization and expansion of Empires
Etc but the other day my son came home
from school and said dad did you know
that tuberculosis partly caused World
War one and I was like what now I was so
proud because of course making
connections between human history and
tuberculosis is my favorite Leisure
activity and it's always a joy to see
your children get involved in what
you're passionate about and also it
turns out the story he told me is true
so World War One began after the
assassination of the austro-hungarian
Archduke Franz Ferdinand and his wife
The Duchess Sophie now I know I
shouldn't say this about a tragedy that
led to the deaths of tens of millions of
people but but the whole thing was kind
of a farce Lake on the one side you had
the wildly in competent support staff of
Archduke Franz Ferdinand and on the
other side you had some wildly
incompetent would-be assassins most of
whom were teenagers now sometimes you
hear the assassination presented as like
some random child Anarchist started
World War one but in fact these child
anarchists were working for a much
larger Network that included like
leaders in the Serbian Army attempting
to liberate Serbia from the
austro-hungarian Empire so yeah they
were kids but the tradition of older men
sending 19 year olds to do War stuff
actually predates 1914 and also
post-dates it right so when it becomes
clear in 1914 that Franz Ferdinand is
going to visit Sarajevo three teenagers
from Belgrade travel there in the hopes
of assassinating him these three young
men are called goodrilo princip najoko
trebrinovich and trifco gabrej and each
of them had been given a gun bombs and a
cyanide pill with instructions to commit
suicide the moment the Archduke was dead
and the prospect of an early death was
made more palatable to these three young
men by the fact that they already faced
an early death as one historian put it
all three were suffering from
tuberculosis and knew they would not
live long they were therefore willing to
give their life for what they believed
was a great cause like earlier in Europe
TB had been romanticized it was seen as
a beautiful way to die and a disease of
civilization and refinement that
affected beautiful and intelligent and
sensitive people but then in 1882 Robert
Koch conclusively proved that
tuberculosis was not caused by being hot
or artsy but instead by a bacterium and
soon TB ceased to be seen as an illness
of civilization and was instead seen as
an illness of contamination and filth
and poverty and those living with it
were hugely stigmatized by their
communities a tradition which by the way
would continue so basically these three
teenage would-be assassins knew they
were already dying once they get to
Sarajevo they meet up with other
co-conspirators and a total of six
people line the parade route with the
idea that one of them surely will
succeed in killing the Archduke what
actually happens is that the first two
kind of lose their courage and then the
third chabrinovic throws a bomb but
misses the archduke's car and it blows
up in underneath another car trip then
takes the cyanide pill which it turns
out doesn't have enough cyanide to kill
him and then jumps into a river which it
turns out is only four inches deep so he
survives and is quickly arrested the
motorcade then shoots off really fast
and the other three assassins are like
oh there's no way we can get him now
he's going too fast and that probably
would have been a good time for Franz
Ferdinand and Sophie to go back to the
hotel but instead one of their
compatriots said what do you think
sarajevo's full of Assassins and
convince them to keep driving around
town and then their driver who did not
know Sarajevo well and could not yet
benefit from GPS took a wrong turn and
then stalled the car while trying to
shift it into reverse I probably don't
need to say this but if you're the
driver for The Heir Apparent to the
austro-hungarian Empire like one thing
you probably should be pretty good at in
1914 is driving a stick shift but right
who should find himself standing right
outside this stalled car but gavrilo
princip he then shoots the Archduke and
Duchess to death and then princess takes
his cyanide pill which again did not
contain enough cyanide to kill him and
so all three of the teenagers who
traveled from Belgrade to Sarajevo to
assassinate the Archduke survived the
assassination were imprisoned and died
within a few years of tuberculosis if
they hadn't known their time was short
would we still have had World War One
probably there were just so many forces
pushing toward a major conflict but we
might have had a different world war one
and I suppose it's possible that we
wouldn't have had one at all I mean
that's the thing that fascinates me
about history so much might happen and
then only one set of things does so in
summary War sucks and tuberculosis also
suck in fact between 1914 the start of
World War One and 1945 the end of World
War II more people died from TB than
died from both those Wars combined Hank
I'll see you on Friday